did it get lonely like can you talk
about some of your experiences of what
it was actually like did it get lonely
yeah no i mean it was um
i didn't have kids at the time now now i
have kids i can't even imagine it um
uh you know i've been married for
five years
at the time my wife hated it i hated it
uh you know i i describe in the book
the experience of being stuck
if i remember correctly it was like ohio
at this truck stop in the middle of
nowhere and like you know sitting on
this concrete barrier and just watching
fireworks in the distance and like
eating chinese food on the 4th of
july and you know my wife calls me from
like the family barbecue
and our anniversary is july 8th and
she's like are you gonna be home and i'm
like
i don't know you know
um
i have a
cousin whose husband drove
drove truck as a truck driver would say
drove truck for a while
um
and he told me before i went into it he
was like the the advantage you have is
that you know that you're not going to
be doing this long term
like and lex i can't even like
the emotional content of some of these
interviews i mean i would sit down at a
truck stop with somebody i had never met
before and you know you open the spigot
and the the the last question i would
ask drivers was
that by the time i really sort of
figured out how to do it the last
question i i would ask them is you know
what advice would you give to somebody
like your nephew you know a family
friend
asks you about what it's like to be a
driver and should they do it what advice
would you give them
and this question
some of these you know grizzled old
drivers you know tough tough guys
would that question would like some of
them would break down and they would say
i would say to them
you better have everything that you ever
wanted in life already
because
i've had a car that i've had for 10
years it's got 7 000 miles on it i own a
boat
that hasn't seen the water in five years
my kids
i didn't raise them like i i'd be out
for two weeks at a time
i'd come home my my wife would give me
two kids to punish a list of things to
do you know on saturday night
and i might leave out sunday night or
monday morning you know i come home dead
tired my kids don't know who i am
and you know it was just like
it was heartbreaking to hear those
stories and before you know it
uh you know life is short and just the
years run away
yeah
hard question to ask in that context but
what's the best what was the best part
of being a truck driver
was there moments uh that you truly
enjoyed on the road oh absolutely there
was um
there's definitely a pride and mastery
of you know even basic competence of
sort of piloting this thing safely
there's a lot of responsibility to it
that thing's dangerous and you know it
so there's there's some pride there for
me personally and i know for a lot of
other drivers it's just like seeing
these behind the scenes places that you
know exist in our economy
um and i think we're all much more aware
of them now after covet and supply chain
mess that we have i don't know if we'll
talk about that but you know
you get to see those places you know you
get to see those ports you get to see
the the place where they make the
cardboard boxes that the huggy diapers
go in huggies diapers going or the
warehouse full of bud light i moved bud
light from like upstate new york and the
first load like went to atlanta
you know and then a couple months later
i circled back through that same brewery
and
i i brought a load of bud light out to
michigan and i was like holy all
the bud light like you know for this
whole giant swath of the united states
comes from this one plant this cavernous
plant with like kegs of beer and you see
that part of the economy and it's like
you're almost like you're an economic
tourist
um and i think all everybody kind of
appreciates that like kind of it's
almost like a behind-the-scenes tour
um
that wears off after a few months you
know you start to see new things less
and less frequently at first
everything's novel and sort of life on
the road and then it becomes just
endless miles of white lines and yellow
lines and truck stops and
the days just blur together um you know
it's one loading dock after another so
you lose the magic of being on the road
yeah it's it's very rare the driver that
doesn't
you